[Music]
foreign
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month today we're heading all the way
back to 2022. it was a big year for the
return of some major franchises with one
flying around on dragons and the other
living on the extra solar Moon known as
Pandora and as the film and television
industry continue to move on from that
hashtag pandemic life we were treated to
some awesomely unique and original
projects and a couple major and I do
mean major sequels so dig out your old
2022 New Year's party favors from the
party stuff bin and get ready because
we're headed back to 2022 right now
[Music]
so I'll never leave here
you'll leave at five
well actually they stagger exit so 5 15.
but it won't feel like it not to this
version of you anyway
do you have a family
you'll never know
premiering on Apple TV Plus in February
was the drama series Severance it was
created by Dan Erickson and what is
considered his first major Hollywood
project an executive produced by Ben
Stiller who also directed six of season
one's nine episodes in it Adam Scott
stars as an employee who agrees to have
his non-work memories separated from his
work memories but when a colleague
mysteriously appears outside of work
they start to discover the truth about
their jobs how many departments are
there probably 35. no one's quite sure
Owen D tried a violent coup on the
others decades ago and that's why they
reduced them down to two and that's why
they keep us all so far apart now that's
an absolute fiction did they ever kill
anyone nope there was no coup no one
killed anyone then why don't we ever
hang out
I mean I'm 99 sure there was no coup
this series was influenced by things
like the urban legend known as the back
rooms The Stanley Parable video game and
the film The Truman Show and that turned
out to be a recipe for Success because
Severance which was renewed for a second
season in April of 2022 was nominated
for 14 Emmy Awards including Outstanding
Drama Series an outstanding lead actor
in a drama for Scott critics say
audacious mysterious and bringing fresh
insight into the Perils of corporate
drudgery Severance is the complete
package
huh
coming in March of 2022 or the March was
the DC film The Batman it was directed
by Matt Reeves with Robert Pattinson
taking over the mantle of Batman where
we find him just in his second year of
fighting crime and adding to the star
power and rebooting of popular
characters is Zoe Kravitz's Catwoman
Paul Dano as the Riddler Jeffrey Wright
as James Gordon and Colin Farrell as the
penguin if you can even tell
foreign
the film was delayed twice from an
original June 2021 release date due to
the covid-19 pandemic before finally
finding a home in 2022 where it became
the seventh highest grossing film of the
year with 770 million dollars worldwide
intended to be a reboot of the Batman
film franchise there is indeed at least
one sequel in the works along with a
couple spin-off television series being
developed for HBO Max critics say a grim
gritty and gripping super Noir the
Batman ranks among the Dark Knights
bleakest and most thrillingly ambitious
live-action outings
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
also arriving in March was one of the
Indie hits of the Year everything
everywhere all at once this one was
written and directed by the Daniels Quan
and sheinert who also produced the film
with the russos Anthony and Joe this
Sci-Fi Action Adventure follows a
chinese-american immigrant played by
Michelle yo who while being audited by
the IRS discovers that she can save the
world by connecting with parallel
universe versions of herself that
Daniels had an idea for a Multiverse
related idea as far back as 2010 and
finally started writing it in 2016 with
the lead role originally written for
Jackie Chan before eventually being
reworked
foreign
with a unique soundtrack that features
artists like David Byrne Andre 3000 and
Randy Newman the film was mostly shot at
a high frame rate to give them more
flexibility to put different parts in
slow motion so cool critics say led by
an outstanding Michelle yo everything
everywhere all at once lives up to its
title with an expertly calibrated
assault on the senses
I'm back
also coming in March via Apple TV plus
was the drama series Pachinko based on
the New York Times best-selling novel of
the same name from 2014. the saga-like
series follows a Korean immigrant family
across four generations as they leave
their Homeland in order to Chase and
fulfill their hopes and dreams
application
the very certified fresh first season
has been a hit with well pretty much
everyone as it's picked up Critics
Choice satellite and Emmy Award
nominations among others which no doubt
helped pave the way for a confirmed
second season critics say intricate yet
intimate Pachinko is a sweeping epic
that captures the Arc of history as well
as the enduring bonds of family
[Music]
foreign
hitting theaters in April was the
Northman directed and co-written by
Robert Eggers who was coming off his
2019 hit the lighthouse starring
Alexander Skarsgard this film is based
on the legend of amleth a figure from a
medieval Scandinavian Legend and the
direct inspiration for the character of
Hamlet
oh your taste and your mind reek of your
father
you should have joined him in death your
words are poisoned I am your dad
[Music]
Skarsgard who was born to a Swedish
family and has been fascinated with
Viking history was actively seeking a
viking themed project so boom it's
Kismet he was joined by stars like
Nicole Kidman Ethan Hawke and Anya
Taylor Joy the latter of whom previously
worked with Eggers on the certified
fresh film The Witch critics say a
bloody Revenge epic and breathtaking
visual Marvel the Northman finds
filmmaker Robert Eggers expanding his
scope without sacrificing any of his
signature Style
setting time to Target two minutes 15
seconds
15 that's impossible file attack Point
Mavericks inbound
[Music]
and buzzing the tower on May 27th was
the sequel 36 years in the making top
gun Maverick with Tom Cruise and Val
Kilmer reprising their roles from 1986's
Top Gun this time Cruz's Maverick
character is tasked with training a
group of younger Top Gun graduates which
includes Miles Teller as rooster the son
of Maverick's late best friend and
co-pilot Goose Cruz insisted that no
green screen or CGI aerial shots be used
in the film so even the close-up cockpit
shots were filmed during actual
in-flight sequences of course that all
added to the action intensity especially
if you saw it in theaters which when
looking at the numbers I'd say most of
us did come on
away
speaking of which after being pushed
from its original July 2019 release so
that they could work out the flight
sequences plus there was a pandemic
thrown in there the film finally opened
in 2022 to rave reviews and huge dollar
signs as in nearly 1.5 billion worldwide
critics say top gun Maverick pulls off a
feat even trickier than a 4G inverted
dive delivering a long belated sequel
that surpasses its predecessor in wildly
entertaining Style
foreign
[Applause]
you got to listen to yourself
do your people Ain't Gonna Change Me
[Applause]
[Music]
hip shaking into theaters in June was
the biopic Elvis directed by baz luhrman
and starring Austin Butler in the
titular role this film Chronicles the
life of Mr Elvis Presley from his early
days to becoming a music and movie star
while centering around his relationship
with manager Colonel Tom Parker played
by Tom Hanks
we're pretty set for the number tomorrow
right
it's pretty familiar territory
Reverend once told me
when things are too dangerous to say
sing
the project was announced announced in
April of 2014 with no further
developments until Hanks was cast in
2019. meanwhile Butler beat out an
impressive list of names being
considered for Elvis including Ansel
Elgort Miles Teller Aaron Taylor Johnson
and Harry Styles Elvis grossed 286
million dollars worldwide which is good
enough to be the second highest grossing
music biopic ever behind 2018's Bohemian
Rhapsody critics say the standard Rock
biopic formula gets All Shook Up in
Elvis with bazlerman's dazzling energy
and style perfectly complemented by
Austin Butler's outstanding lead
performance
okay
[Music]
yeah no no no no no
no
showing up in July was nope which was
written directed and produced by Jordan
peel and came on the heels of his other
hit horror flicks get out and US Daniel
kaluya and Kiki Palmer star in this one
as a brother and sister who make a
chilling Discovery in the skies above
their California horse ranch peel wrote
the script with kaluya in mind after
previously working with him on get out
and also brought in actors like Steven
Yoon Keith David and Brandon perea to
round out the cast
[Music]
and Peel's signature Unique Style
continues to impress both fans and
critics as the certified fresh film
picked up a bunch of nominations and
awards along the way and maybe just
maybe a sequel could be coming from this
one maybe critics say admirable for its
originality and ambition even when its
reach exceeds its grasp nope adds
spielbergian spectacle to Jordan Peel's
growing Arsenal
[Music]
my brother's city has fallen into
squalor
crime of every breed has been allowed to
thrive
no longer beginning tonight King's
Landing will learn to fear the color
gold
and to keep the heat of the summer going
August brought the premiere of HBO's
House of the Dragon This Game of Thrones
prequel series is once again based on
novels by George RR Martin and is set
200 years before the events of Game of
Thrones it tells the story of the
beginning of the end of the House
Targaryen a family of dragonlords the
series premiere was considered the
biggest in HBO's history with over 10
million viewers across the linear
channels and HBO Max so it's no surprise
that a second season renewal came less
than a week after the premiere let us
drain our cups
to these three
strong boys I tell you to say that again
why
it was only a compliment
do you not think Yourself Strong
plus House of the Dragon earned multiple
Golden Globe Critics Choice and People's
Choice Award nominations for what is yet
another intriguing story from the mind
of George RR Martin critics say covering
an era of tenuous peace with ferocious
albeit abbreviated Focus House of the
Dragon is an impressive prequel that
exemplifies the court Intrigue that
distinguished its predecessor
[Music]
ancestors are mine we rip the shackles
of Doubt from our minds and fight with
courage
we fight not just for today
but for the future we
are the spirit of victory
we are the plane of freedom
ascending the throne in September of
2022 was the woman King directed by Gina
Prince Blythewood and starring Viola
Davis this historical film is about the
agoji an all-female Warrior unit that
protected the West African Kingdom of
Dahomey from the 17th to the 19th
centuries
foreign
[Applause]
the idea for this story was conceived by
Maria Bello one of The film's Producers
after she visited Africa where the
kingdom used to be located and learned
the history of the egoji the woman King
opened at number one at the box office
and went on to earn 83 million dollars
worldwide against a 50 million dollar
budget plus it confirmed what we all
knew that Viola Davis is a complete and
utter badass critics say all hail Viola
Davis the woman King rules
[Music]
foreign
lighting up theaters in October was the
highly anticipated Black Adam the film
stars Dwayne Johnson who after much
prodding from fans and plenty of work on
his end was finally able to make the
movie happen Black Adam is an anti-hero
of sorts who is enslaved for 5 000 years
for pursuing Justice in his own way in a
place called kandak before being
Unleashed in modern times for this story
foreign
[Music]
the film which was directed by Jama
Colette Sarah of House of Wax and the
shallows Fame introduced the group known
as the Justice Society of America which
in the comics included a character named
Dr Faith played by Pierce Brosnan in
this movie Black Adam also introduced
Hawkman played by Aldous Hodge and
Cyclone played by Contessa Swindle and
while critics didn't love it and the box
office numbers could barely recoup the
film's budget fans are loving the
character and hoping for more to come
critics say Black Adam may end up
pointing the way to an exciting future
for DC films but as a standalone
experience it's a wildly uneven letdown
we're going to use Daddy's camera to
film it
only crash the train once okay then
after we get the film developed you can
watch it crash over and over till it's
not so scary anymore
and your real train won't ever get
broken
let's not tell your father
's in mine
and with the calendar switch to November
came the latest Steven Spielberg
offering the Fable men's a
semi-autobiographical story based on
Spielberg's adolescence and first years
as a filmmaker the cast features
Michelle Williams Paul Dano Seth Rogen
and Gabriel LaBelle the latter of whom
plays young Sami fableman Who falls in
love with movies in post-world War II
era Arizona and starts to make his own
at home I'm asking you to do this now
for your mom yes and I said that I will
just not tomorrow don't be selfish she
just lost her mother
that's more important than your hobby
okay can you stop calling it a hobby
it'll cheer
I think
because you made it for her along with
this Stellar cast and Spielberg's touch
the film also features music by The One
and Only John Williams and while it
didn't do much in theaters the Fable
men's was a film festival darling and is
widely considered to be one of the best
films of the year with plenty of award
love to back it up critics say part
Memoir part owed to the power of the
movies the Fable men's find Steven
Spielberg digging at the family roots
that helped make him a beloved filmmaker
and proves he hasn't lost his Magic
Touch
where is your speech should he gave me
this to try
[Music]
you know I like them better our four
mothers gave us its fear because it is
precise elegant and
deadly
it will not change under my watch also
opening in November was Black Panther
wakanda forever the sequel to 2018's
Black Panther and the final film in the
mcu's phase four it was directed by Ryan
coogler who co-wrote the screenplay with
Joe Robert Cole holding the same roles
they did for the first film and while
plans began immediately following the
first installment the death of Chadwick
Boseman in 2020 shifted things and
ultimately gave Leticia Wright who plays
t'challa's sister shuri a larger role
get out of my dorm get out
hey I'm warning you do not take another
step toward me
see how they teach the children to treat
their guests
oh
despair in here I like it wakanda
forever also introduces ironheart played
by Dominic Thorne a genius inventor with
a suit of armor like Iron Man Who also
has her own self-titled series coming to
Disney plus the film pulled in over 820
million dollars worldwide as one of the
highest Grocers of the year and received
plenty of award show love especially for
Angela Bassett and her performance as
ramonda the mother of t'challa critics
say a poignant tribute that satisfyingly
moves the franchise forward black
panther wakanda forever marks an
ambitious and emotionally rewarding
Triumph for the MCU
this is our home
I need you with me and I need you to be
strong
[Music]
and finally splashing its way into
theaters in December was the
long-awaited Avatar The Way of water
directed by James Cameron this marks the
second installment in the franchise
following 2009's Avatar this one is set
more than a decade after the first film
and finds Sam worthington's Jake Sully
now settled down with his family
including Zoe Saldana as his wife natiri
as they must work together with others
in the navi race to fight a familiar
threat and protect their home treat them
as our brothers and sisters
teach them our ways
how far is boy
do you want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
the film was initially slated for a 2014
release but later pushed in order to
develop new technology to film
performance capture scenes underwater
when things did finally get underway the
budget was a reported 250 million
dollars making it one of the most
expensive films of all time but hey you
gotta spend money to make money and that
is just what Avatar the way of water is
done after the 11th best worldwide
opening weekend ever it eventually
crossed a 1.4 billion dollar Mark in
worldwide ticket sales in January of
2023 and even though it took 13 years
between the first and second
installments the next three sequels are
set to be released in December of 2024
December of 2026 and December of 2028
sure they are critics say narratively it
might be fairly standard stuff but
visually speaking Avatar the way of
water is a stunningly immersive
experience holy cow we did it who knew
that looking back on all the big movies
and shows of 2022 would be so much fun
well we did actually that's why we do
this show anyway what was your favorite
title from the year and was there
anything we left out do let us know
thanks for checking out our year in
review for 2022. we'll see you in the
future for more discussions about the
past